but yeah there's like a there's a like  you know I'm not happy with what I look  like so I'm just gonna pretend like it  doesn't matter kind of attitude and  that's the thing like I honestly think  and you know what I I'm a really  long-term thinker and so a big reason  that I wanted to get my eating habits  under control because that's just  something that has never in my life come  natural I've always been easy for me to  work out go to the gym that's easy  what's always been hard for me is sugar  I freaking love sugar I love I do I love  I love dessert I love pizza like I just  love that stuff and I've gotten slowly  like better over time right and it's  kind of funny I look at myself like 10  years ago I was so I was thinner because  but I was like I was so much worse